hey everybody it's mike from order flows
and welcome to
this special training video on the order
flows flow
driver now in this presentation
i'll be talking about the settings the
general settings and the effect that
they have
on the indicator i'll be talking about
which trades to take and i'll jump
into you know the different markets and
what sort of settings you want to be
using for them alright so just bear with
me and let me
get my screen up my trading screen
make sure i got the right screen here we
go okay so this is a normal
footprint chart and the flow driver is
added on you can see there's
uh red down triangles for cells and you
have
blue up triangles for buys now
you don't have to use a footprint chart
for this indicator you can use a normal
um bar chart i'll be flipping between
footprint charts and bar charts
sometimes it's so i could show a bit
more on
a bar chart than i can on a footprint
chart in terms of screen space
but in the settings okay so you can
adjust
the color of the up and down
triangle you know for the buy signals
the cell signals
by going under the plots you could see
it right here right say you don't like
blue
you know you can change it to whatever
color cyan teal whatever
you don't like red for cells you can
change it to whatever color you know
magenta or whatever but you know
in general blue means by red means cell
in
trading and you can even make the size
of the triangle bigger
you i use eight but you know if you want
it really big you could do something
like
15 or 16. um if you want smaller you can
make it smaller
but you know eight i find is is good
enough for me on my eyes
all right so after you enter your
license token in here
the settings the main settings are are
found right under
the part that says settings now there's
the swing filter
which you can enable or disable right
right now i have it on this chart as
disabled right to enable it i would
click on
that little box there and here you see
swing period right the next one
right below it alright so it's set at 1
so
if i have this enabled whatever value i
put in here
right starting at one you're not going
to enable it and put it at zero because
you just disable it right if you have
swing period set to zero then
it's not going to use it and you you
know don't do that just disable it if
you don't want to use it
now you could use a period of like one
two three four five you know six seven
eight nine ten
i know some people use a very high swing
period
okay they use it all the way up to um 50
but then it's going to depend on their
strength and all so you know i find
either
some markets i prefer to disable it and
see all the signals
or i use a swing period of one two or
three
or five or nine it really depends on you
and the market you're trading and how
many signals
you want to see on your chart basically
and i'll tell you what let me pull up a
chart here okay so this is ultra bonds
all right so i will
just show you the differences it's going
to make so here i got swing filter
disabled right it's unchecked but if i
check it
and set it to one okay some of these
signals
might not appear anymore let me just
make this a little smaller
okay so um
this one won't this one won't this one
won't
so click apply
let it work okay so you see just one
signal there
right all the others disappeared um
disable it and it's basically i like
using
no swing filter on markets where
i like to scalp trades basically you
know things like um
some of the grain markets and ultra
bonds bonds
i'm looking for many signals in those
markets i have
the balance and balance strength set to
pretty low levels all right so
let's take a look at um a different
example here
this is e minis
okay well let's get to current day
where are we here
um if
let's tell you what let me change it to
something a bit
more uh volatile change it to
nq now
i want to take a look at the settings
real quick as far as the strength but
when you when you're on a more volatile
market
if you set the strengths
kind of weak you know kind of loose in a
sense
then you're going to get a lot of
signals okay and
the reason being is because that's due
to the volatility in the market
right you know a market like nasdaq
not only has a lot of volatility but
part of the reason you got a lot of
volatility is because the
the market doesn't have that same
liquidity that the more
uh deeper markets like yes has right
like the e-minis
have and that's going to affect
basically the way the indicator
finds trades right because if
in other words right because remember
right this is reading the order flow so
it's it's based on
um volume that's traded
as well as overall volume that's being
traded
all right so it's taking it in
relationship so if you've got
weaker volume then weaker volume
internally in the bar
and you set the the strength pretty low
it's going to give you a lot of signals
so you can see here right there's a lot
of signals
right and then people would be like
scratching their head you know jesus
this is stupid you know it's like every
other
well not every other bar but every you
know couple minutes there there's a
signal
all right and that's due to having a low
setting i know it's low on this one
uh sorry um and i know it's
this one is set to average before on the
e mini chart i had it set to zero but if
i had so example if i had it set to zero
right balance disabled there's going to
be a lot more signals
right and even you know two is about
average on the strength
here you know minimum is one right
maximum is three so it's right in the
middle on
balanced strength but
if i turn off the balance basically you
know one would be the lowest
if it's turned on zero would be disabled
there's going to be a lot more signals
you know even if i change the balance
strength to one
as well right there'll be a lot more
signals but let's
let's let this come up first and then
i'll talk about it
let's give it a second here whoops
because that down doesn't get in the way
but you know the default i believe is
two and two which is
basically the midpoints on a lot but
when you set the
balance to zero basically disable it
that's about as
weak as it can get on the balance now
if you're going to set on a market
that's volatile like nasdaq right if
you're going to set the balance at a low
number
the actual balance strength you're going
to want to set at a higher number so you
see there's a lot more signals here
so one of the ways that you can filter
out is by using
a swing filter okay and if i change it
to one which is just
the the bare minimum one right zero
or disable it would be no swing filter
um setting it to swing filter with the
one is is the minimum now i could later
after this comes up i just want you to
show you the difference
um with between one and zero right we
saw a lot of signals there
but now i'm going to change it to 1 and
it's going to clean it up a lot
because it's looking for basically at a
setting of
1 it's looking for bars
where the market is seems to be turning
a little bit at a bare minimum so you
can see here right
you got to sell here a buy a buy a buy
sell sell a cell
okay so before you had
a lot more signals now you've got less
now that's a setting of one
now you could expand it a bit say you
don't want to use one say you want to
use you know sort of a longer period
five
you know i like one three five and nine
that that's me
but and depending on the market okay of
course
um you know some markets that don't move
a lot i i wouldn't use
uh a particular swing filter um
just because you know it's it's not
really
going to have much effect on it um but i
don't know how to phrase it
it's it's one of those things where you
have to know how your market trades you
have to understand
how your market trades so that you know
you can take advantage of
when the market is actually turning or
not okay
so here right now it's set to five and
you only got two signals
okay now
if i set you know if i start were to
start changing the balance on these
things it's going to also affect the
amount of signals i get
so i'll just uncheck that i'll just put
this back at the defaults
two and two and just sort of go through
the other settings here
so delta analysis okay what that means
is
if you want to use delta in
the market analysis so basically if
you enable it okay
a bar is going to have to have positive
delta
if it's an up bar or negative delta if
it's a down bar
because you know sometimes there are
bars that
have positive delta that are red bars
right that are going down
and why is that why do they have
positive delta if the market is going
down is because
you have aggressive buyers buying the
offer buying it from
you know the passive traders there but
the passive traders have
a lot of supply okay and you know that
means one thing
in the market that means that there's
you know resistance in the market
basically because you know people
you know what causes resistance right
what causes a market to go up and hit
resistance well
resistance occurs when there's a lot of
supply in the market right because it's
going up but then people sellers come in
and offer it out okay so here right this
is
with delta analysis turned off i'll turn
it on
there's going to be
not a lot less there's going to be
generally
a few less signals i mean that generally
on up candles you have positive deltas
on down candles you have
negative delta but
once in a while like i said you get the
opposites okay and
it actually has a a negative a negative
meaning but
it's got a different meaning in the
order flow okay you know you don't want
to be buying into supply
all right or selling into support right
you want to be doing the opposite
so that's what the delta analysis
tool or filter rather tool um
is for okay and as i said it's going to
filter out a few signals
not a whole heck of a lot but just a few
um so you can see here this is slightly
less
all right there's a nice nice move here
from
you know the 82s all the way up into the
double o's here
oh it's a nice move this is the
overnight session by the way i just
use this because this was always on my
chart um all right so that's the delta
analysis turned on
it's up to you if you want to use it now
type markets okay
type markets you could enable it
or disable it and basically what it's
for when i was
first using this form of analysis on
order flow
um you only when you start looking at
markets let me just
get a market up here for example
um treasuries five years okay we'll take
a look at fives
fives and um you know bonds
ten years they tend to have very
tight bars you know tight ranges you
know here
trading just a bit in the offer or
trading the bid in the offer it's what i
call a tight market
because it's basically it's the bid and
offer and there's big size up
right if you were to look at 10 years um
you know it's very it's probably even
tighter because you know 10 years is
like
six six and a half thousand up
but then behind it is 5 000 you know the
next bid another 5 000 on the offer
um 10 000 above it 10 000 below it like
that it was very liquid
um so and as a result of that liquidity
it
you don't get necessarily the same price
movements that you would get and say
crude oil right or
e-minis now if i was trading
a market like this you know this was a
filter that we put on
um specifically for these these
markets like this and if you disable it
right then you're probably not gonna get
any signals in the
um in the treasury markets you know or
buns even you know the 10 years
in germany and you know we sort of went
back and forth and just you know to
just make it fully enabled or not but
you know we just we had it as a filter
in there
um first you know for people that trade
the night session
and then want to trade the day session
right if because honestly if you're
trading something like nq
at night you know volume is a lot lesser
e-mini's volume is a lot lesser
whereas during the day you know you
might want to have have it disabled
but for markets that don't have a lot of
volatility very low volatility
you definitely want to have it enabled
things like e-minis
it's not going to make a difference
whether it's enabled or disabled
and qym you know the market said trade
normally
you know euro currencies um crude oil
but if you are trading something like
treasuries
you're definitely going to want to have
it enabled
so you know market like treasuries you
don't get a lot of signals
but you know here's ultra bonds take a
look at treasuries uh
i don't know if there's going to be any
in there you know treasuries is a hard
market sometimes to
read the order flow because the order
flows is so
big in the sense that it's not going to
give you like here's one it's a scalpers
you know it's a market you know people
that trade it basically trade it's
the you know they come in they trade 100
200 contracts to make a half a tick
then they're done all right so
uh 10 years i don't think is a great
market for just the retail trader
you know an interesting market i think i
mean obviously you have the ultra bonds
but
the five years you know it used to be a
very
nice market to trade you know it's got
low margin if you look at amp it's only
like a couple hundred bucks
um now not a lot of signals i mean there
was one there
but you just have to go on and adjust
the
settings right i got tight markets on um
balance strength
you know maybe you want to set it a
little bit lower
but it's one of those markets that you
know when it starts it can have
some nice moves when it's um
when it's moving you know problem is you
don't necessarily get a lot of moves
anymore in these markets yeah
not much on that's on the one minute
chart but
if you were to expand it say a two
minute chart um
it might look a little bit different you
know there's a buy there's a cell
uh here's a nice buy on that move um
you know there's a nice little cell here
nice little cell there this one did
nothing you know and some movements
overnight oh even a
five minute chart right this is the five
years
excuse me
you know here's the cell here here's the
buy here's the cell
you're starting to see some more signals
you know when you start expanding the
the time out on a chart or on a market
that trades
um you know generally pretty quiet but
that one
again i had set the this balance
strength
pretty low all right so let me just uh
go back to sort of a norm another
markets
uh this one is my ultra bond charts so
let me just go back to ultra bonds
but let's go back to a one minute chart
the balance equality is
right here balance equality it's enabled
and basically what the balance equality
setting is is looking for it's looking
for equal balance
minimum in the bar there's going to be
times
generally you're going to want to have
an imbalance in the bar
either buying or selling but there are
times where
it comes literally equal
okay and is it coincidence you know
because you could be talking about the
difference of
one or two you know a contract basically
which is you know one trade
um and you know when you're dealing with
certain types of bars you know
especially
time based charts you know the market
just closes boom right on that time so
it's it could just be end up at equal
for whatever
reason okay so that's why we have it you
know if i was using something like a
range based chart i'd probably disable
it but
it's just safer to have it on um
completely you don't need to disable it
because
honestly it's not going to make that big
a difference in in most
markets but it's just one of those
things that we found where you know
where it just comes in
where it comes in equal you sort of you
got to make a decision
right where the
the balance is equal and you're like
well
because you know when you're programming
right you got to have it it's either got
to be above a number you know
zero it's got to be a positive or it's
going to be negative but what happens if
it falls on zero
right do you want to take those i want
to take those but again that's the
option
if you don't want to take them okay
so this is my ultrabond chart all right
and you know you can see those signals
but
let's take a look at you know some other
markets because
you know in the user guide i give you
guys some settings right but
not all markets you know you're probably
going to want to use
the exact same settings so we'll we'll
first start with
well this is gold okay um
and i'll just sort of you know go
through you know why you'd want to use
certain settings now this
one is set at two and two okay
which is is the mid-range right and for
most markets
it's generally going to be um you know
pretty decent
all right you can see some nice moves
here in the morning
um you know the moves down the sharp
moves down right that's what flow driver
really is trying to look for starting to
look for those moves
those sharp moves right before they
happen
okay now there's going to be times where
it sort of sputters like you have
you know here in the middle right right
here
right you but really flow's driver is
designed to catch those big sharp drops
or or rallies you know when they're
about to occur right here the big sharp
drop
right big sharp drops here all right
boom
and this is a setting of two and two
right now we all want to have trades
where
you know you sell it and it drops and
then you buy it and it just rallies
you know back up you know the v shape
moves but the market doesn't move that
way
right the sharp drops don't always occur
as frequently as we like right sometimes
you're gonna get stuck you know you're
gonna get some sideways activity here
um you know sideways activity comes
before sharp moves
okay now this is a setting of of two and
two okay
now again that's the average if you were
to take a look at e-minis
let's take a look here
now e-mini's is you know kind of a
unique market in the sense that there's
a lot of different trading going on you
know when you're trading a commodity
market
things are different than when you're
trading a
you know a commodity market is different
than trading something that's
cash settled like e-minis where you got
a lot of retail activity you got a lot
of
institutional activity you got a lot of
hedging activity you really got you know
this big
mix so what i do
you know whenever i come to a new market
right i always say okay i want to see
how it's going to work
i basically set these almost as low as i
can go
you know one and zero but i want to keep
the strength on
or sorry the strength is one and the
balance i keep to one
and yeah that's where i started i
started at one and one strength of one
balance of one and you know that that's
where i start and that's where i go from
right if if i think that
you know one is giving me too many
signals
meaning that it's set too low then i'll
change it to two
right or i'll change it to three two
being the average
will work for most markets um
three you know is the highest right the
highest i would use in on more volatile
markets so here's one
in one um you know is it
good i don't know it's okay you know
right now cash opened
and a lot of back and forth here
basically between 53 and 58
but you know when you take a look at
what happened overnight
okay got a little move here then you got
this nice move from 42
you know basically all the way up to 50s
52 that's a 10 point move in the s ps
there
um you know again here in the evening
nice little move up
you know got that sharp move down got
this little move up
yesterday this uh that's the 23rd
you know it caught this nice move down
this move didn't happen
you know i know there are people are
going to watch my video and they'll say
well
you had a losing trade here you had a
losing trade here
okay well you know that's trading that's
why you use stops right because
you're looking for a move to happen and
if it doesn't happen you get stopped out
wait for the next trade right they don't
mention anything about this
this move from 39 all the way up to 44
then from 44 back down to 39
37 right that's 10 points
right there but there's they're they're
stuck on this
losing trade okay you lose your point
your point and a half two points but you
just made five points here five points
there
you know you made something here you
made something here right
now not every trade is going to give you
five points you know depending on the
type of trader you are
right you've got to decide what type of
trader you are that's why
you know i'm always a bit hesitant on
giving settings
out to people because i don't know what
type of trader you are
you know you can be a scalper you could
be more of someone that wants to hold it
for
an hour or two or hold it all day so it
really depends
all right so that's one in one you know
that's kind of what i even though i just
said i don't want to really recommend
settings for markets you know
one and one i find is is pretty decent
pretty good for
e-mini's now let's take a look at you
know another
market mini dow right stay on
stay on the stock side of it okay now
mini dao is not as volatile as
nasdaq but it has some volatility okay
so
this is the same settings one and one
okay
i mean it looks okay you know at first
glance but for a lot of people there's a
lot of trades happening
right you know you might not be
interested in it and depending on the
time of day you trade
you know it might not be you know good
for you
right some people i know like to have a
lot of trades because you're just
looking to scalp scout skull scup sculpt
this move up scalp this move down
um so now on a market that's a little
bit more volatile right i said you're
going to want to have
a slightly higher strength right so you
can you know go up to two there
you know go up to two but let's make it
three right let's make it the max
all right three and two max on balance
strength balance we'll just keep it
average
click apply click okay and you're going
to see it it's going to give you
bus signals okay which is fine right
it's not that
you want to be uh you know catching
signals
you know left and right so here's a bit
stronger and it's a bit cleaner
right look at that it's a bit cleaner
now
all right less signals right but the
signals that you're getting
are better i don't say better but you
know you've filtered out a lot of the
weaker you know the paper hand signals
if you know
they use a a phrase people say well
you got short here then the market
rallied okay you know
you got to have a stop right you know
you're trading right ahead of cash open
you know
could be a flood of orders coming in
which happened and the market rallied
so that's ym right
now gold and silver right i showed you
gold let's take a look at silver
since we're talking about commodities
silver um now
okay so this is the settings that i just
had left over from
the mini dial right and you know it's
okay
you know it's not bad you know it's
catching this this nice
move down here from 26 12 all the way
down to
you know 25 80 90 right in here
um that's kind of a strong signal three
and
two right you know commodities i like to
start out at two and two
right one so it's a market i'm coming
into um
you know i always want to start here and
it's it's you know it's very similar
you know you catch that nice jump up
that nice move down there
um you know in the evening session here
when jp morgan is manipulating the
silver markets
um you know
you want to catch those moves you know
it's funny you know because i i worked
at jp morgan and
sometimes i get these emails from people
saying
accusing me of market manipulation which
is just utter nonsense
just because you know i worked at jp
morgan i'm sure they probably
if they found somebody that worked in
the uh in cleaning the toilets they
would
attack them for manipulating the silver
market it's uh
it's ridiculous i even
you know my buddies and i used to work
with there at jp morgan we
we we joke about it because you know
was there manipulation i don't know you
know that that's a completely different
trading department than
than where i was i was in futures you
know the guys on the bullion desk
um you know set
on the opposite side of the trade of the
floor
not just you know not like of the room
but
on the opposite side of the floor so
imagine you know a big building
i'm on the the east side sorry i was on
the west side
they're on the east side no interaction
with them at all
whatsoever um and obviously a lot of the
stuff happens out of london anyway and i
was in singapore
but anyway you can see you know you want
to catch those big
moves right it's looking for those pops
sometimes the pops happen
sometimes they don't so this is two and
two
okay setting up two and two
and that's why using gold and and silver
now
crude oil
uh crude
oil crude oil crude oil
the way i would describe it the way it
trades
is it's a bit like e-mini's
you get a lot of the same players but to
a lesser degree
um it feels like and it's up to 73 bucks
now this is with two and two okay
there's nothing wrong with two and two
two and two is the average right and
that's
a good starting point for a lot of
people but you know i do
suggest um if you're coming into a new
market
you know that you may not have been
trading for a long time start with one
and one
and go from there one in one is what i
recommend for e-minis
and you know crude i find it's got
similar movement
to e-mini so i you know the settings i
would start with
is one-in-one to see how how it performs
you know 101 is giving me a lot of
signals um
so i don't know you know one and one or
two and two but um
there's nothing wrong with one and one
you know i was catching some nice moves
day before
yeah it catches this nice move from 7360
you know down to 30 then back up from
o5 back up into you know the 20s
there's nice moves to be had in these
markets right and close driver
really is designed to sort of capture
those
those moves you know before they start
um
because there there are signs in the
order flow
before it's going to happen before it
you know actually happens so
let's take a look at well let's go back
to a footprint chart
soybeans soybeans has been pretty active
the last
couple of days a lot of price movements
and such
this is soybeans right now what do i got
on the flows driver here
now
um two and zero
it should be okay okay so the other
thing i want to talk about like if
you're using a footprint chart you can
even do it on a normal
bar chart under the visuals right you
have
how you know where things are going to
appear but this one signal box with
right here is basically going to draw
out the zone
for you okay so set it to five and and
you know if you're familiar with some of
my earlier indicators you know what the
zone is it's this right here
right it's drawing out the zone telling
you you know this is
the area you should be getting short
because you got a signal coming in here
right
you know here's the buys right here as
this market is coming up
now the opacity is kind of light it's
set to 20 i think
or this one if i set the five so it's a
little hard to see if you look under
yeah opacity you know you can set it
higher to 50.
you don't want to set it to 100 because
then it would just be too bright but 50
is
strong so you can see you know and
you're going to use these as your
you're basically your stop level right
if you're getting long you've got the
signal and you're getting long
if you start trading into here you gotta
worry if you get on the other side you
should get out
right that's where i know where to place
my stop it's on the other side of these
zones
but on the indicator it is um
set to zero so they're not appearing but
you know you should
you know plug them in i mean this is a
nice move here from a nice short from 72
all the way down into you know the six
oh got only down to 62. um
then it rallied back up from 67 you know
all the way back up
to 77 up to the 80s right now it's
coming back down it's giving you some
sell signals here
okay so and that is with the setting of
two and zero right you don't have to use
two and zero two and one
you know is so this is a setting that i
like to use for
grains as well it's going to give you a
lot of the same signals here
you know so there's a lot of nice
activity to be had in the grain markets
there
now the other thing i want to talk about
really quick is the trade entry signal
people ask me
what is this trade entry signal do i
need to use it or not
i use it and what it does is it
when it's enabled right you can see two
and two right trade price level and tax
trade validity and bars
is two so basically what that means is
for a signal to
occur for an actual trade to be
valid the market has to move two ticks
in the direction of the trade over the
next two bars so you can see here right
you got the zones drawn out so the bar
in the conditions in this bar and this
bar
are met to get short but there's no
follow through order flow that's why you
don't see
the red triangle like you see up here
okay now if i have trade entry signal
turned off
let me just turn it off here it will
give you
the red triangle okay telling you to
take the trade
now the reason i have this is because on
some indicators like um
i'm sorry not some indicators on some
tools like markers right if we're trying
to automate it
you know you want to take the trade when
conditions are met so you can see
get short get short but you don't get
short here right because the market
didn't sell off any further
you want it here where the market's sold
off okay now with
again you don't have to use two and two
you could use mark it's got to move one
tick in the next one bar
right or it's got to move um
want two ticks over the next five bars
it really depends on how you want to use
it i use two and two
and you'll notice right see here
up here the triangle is above the signal
bar just as
here you got a buy signal right if it's
enabled
you're not going to get the buy signal
here
you have your cell signal here because
it's coming on the bar where the order
flow came in to confirm it
right this is your bar that says hey you
know what the driver is in effect here
and then follow-up order flow comes in
this is where you're getting short as
soon as it appears
just as you have no sell signal here no
sell signal here so it kept you out of
this losing trade this losing trade this
losing trade
got you in on this trade got you in on
this trade got you in on that trade
now people will say do i you know
like well why are you giving up you know
you know the
market is bullish here why don't you
just get long well you still need that
follow-through order flow
right you still need that buying if
you're getting long to come in after you
bought
right you don't want to get short here
but then it's just buying comes in right
you don't want that you want to get
short
like here and have selling come in right
so that's where you're getting short
here
even though it's you know in this case
one bar after the bar
where everything signals so
you know that's basically the flows
driver you know on how to use it
i don't want to get into you know
settings you know i really want you to
you know for particular markets i want
you to learn your market right so you
understand how to trade your market
and what works best for you i'll give
you a framework and you go from there if
you want to use it
fine you know but at the same time every
market is
different and every trader is different
we all got different risk levels
risk parameters we don't all trade
um you know with the same amount of risk
you know some people the market goes
four ticks against them they're
panicking whereas other people the
market goes 10 ticks against them
they're they're fine they're not no
sweat
you know so it really depends on how
many signals you want to get
you know and how volatile your market is
so you know on that note we'll end
this training so i hope you enjoyed it
and you know any questions on the flows
driver
just shoot me an email okay so thanks
everyone and bye bye